Порожні вулиці, повсюди - сліди від російських обстрілів.
Через півтора місяця після деокупації Херсон нагадує місто-привид.
За даними місцевої влади, до війни в Херсоні проживали 330 тисяч людей.
Нині лишилося не більше п'ятої частини - 60 тисяч.
Щодня по обіді на міському вокзалі стає людно.
Звідси відправляється єдиний потяг - до Києва.
До нього приєднані три евакуаційні вагони, які прямують до Хмельницького.
Для багатьох херсонців це порятунок від постійних ударів російської артилерії.
Велика родина Іванчуків виїхала з села Токарівка на північ від Херсона.
Як і більшість людей в евакуаційному вагоні, вони не знають, що на них чекає попереду.
Але впевнені, що гірше вже не буде.
Немає нічого: ні води, ні світла. Я кажу, Владік на світло дивиться.
Коли ти в останній раз бачив? При свічках, при каганці, при ліхтариках.
До останнього сиділи, до останнього. Але там не можна вже було залишатися, не можна.
Оксана з чоловіком жили в селищі Антонівка, біля славнозвісного мосту.
Після прильотів у сусідні двори вони наважилися виїжджати.
Коли ти боїшся бути в будинку в себе, боїшся вийти на вулицю, боїшся пройти по вулиці - це не життя.
Спиш у підвалі. Якщо вдома перебуваєш, то намагаєшся, щоб речі були під рукою,
щоб раптом треба тікати - документи схопив, взувся і побіг. Це дуже страшно.
У херсонця Анатолія взагалі не лишилося вибору.
Його будинок зруйнований вщент.
Меблі всі, документи. Я займаюся підводними зйомками, в експедиціях з американцями був - підводна археологія.
Усі роботи за десять років, обладнання водолазне…
Після ночі в дорозі евакуаційний потяг прибуває до Хмельницького.
- Вітаємо вас на Хмельниччині! - Дякуємо. - Зараз працюємо таким чином…
Зараз ви отримаєте допомогу одноразову для людей з деокупованих територій.
Після того, як ви поїдете або на розселення, або до своїх родичів,
стаєте на облік як внутрішньо переміщена особа за місцем проживання.
Хмельниччина приймає переселенців з Херсона з 26 листопада, а від початку війни - людей з усієї України.
Нині, кажуть в обласній адміністрації, у самому Хмельницькому місця для переселенців закінчилися.
У нас повністю з березня місяця місць, на жаль, немає, у зв'язку з тим,
що близько 40 тисяч внутрішньо переміщених осіб проживають у місті Хмельницькому.
До війни населення нараховувалося 270 тисяч.
Тобто на даний час, на жаль, у місті Хмельницькому місць немає.
Евакуйованих з Херсона розселяють в області - у школах і садочках, які не працюють, або в гуртожитках.
Цей автобус попрямує до школи в селі Борщівка за 80 км від міста.
Там у нас є дві душові кабіни, там у нас є дві електроплити на 8 конфорок.
Умови в нас нормальні, як на мене, досить комфортно, тепло, чисто.
Тому просимо підтримувати і думаємо, все буде добре.
Валентина з Херсона розповідає, що деякі її знайомі виїхали з Херсона в Росію.
Утім, для неї було принциповим залишитися в Україні.
Водночас умови для переселенців на Хмельниччині стали для неї несподіванкою.
Ми не думали, що нас поселять у садочок чи в гуртожиток.
Чи може хоч якийсь центр, знаєте, щоб у сім'ї була окрема кімната, бо ми всі з дітьми, з мамами, з бабусями.
Ось сім'я теж - чоловік і дружина і дітки, і кажуть, що будуть селити або в садочок усіх разом,
або в гуртожиток, теж усіх разом. Через це засмутилися.
У родини Іванчуків з села Токарівка поки лише позитивні враження.
Подобається, що є світло. Купа руху.
Діти теж кажуть: бабусю, наче цивілізація - тихо, ніде не стріляють, наче і війни немає.
Ця відремонтована сільська школа стане для херсонців новим домом - принаймні на деякий час.
Проходьте туди, будь ласка, всередину.
Цей заклад, у якому ми перебуваємо, розрахований на те, що люди тут будуть проживати рік, два, п'ять, тому що заклад не діючий.
Якщо садочок, у тій самій Радковиці, якщо ми відновимо навчальний процес, люди там не зможуть проживати,
ми будемо їх просити відшукати собі інше місце для проживання, бо діти мусять отримувати освіту.
У колишній Борщівській школі уже живуть переселенці з Херсона.
Серед них - Віктор Кривобородько, колись перший шериф України.
Наглядав за порядком у селі Стара Збурівка на Херсонщині, де вперше в Україні запровадили таку посаду.
Це село на лівому березі Дніпра, воно досі окуповане.
А Херсон більше не може слугувати для Віктора і його дружини прихистком.
Прожили в Херсоні поки нормально, у родичів жили.
Коли 24-го - приход, прилетіло прямо під вікно і всі осколки зібрала собі в спину. Чотири осколки.
Якби я поранення не отримала, ми б із Херсона не виїхали, навіть якби і бомбили.
Ми б сиділи там і чекали, а раптом лівий берег… І додому… Ми ж там поруч.
Життям на Хмельниччині Віктор і Ольга задоволені, хоч і мріють повернутися додому.
Місцева громада раз на день безкоштовно годує обідами, благодійні фонди передають гуманітарну допомогу.
Крім виплат для внутрішньо переміщених осіб від держави,
безкоштовно видають продукти харчування на місяць і одяг.
Водночас новоприбулі херсонці по-різному оцінюють умови, які надає держава.
Влаштувалися нормально, прийняли нормально, усім задоволені.
Спокійні, що не будемо очікувати, де воно прилетить.
Не сподобалося те, що кладовище поруч.
Ось у нас вид на кладовище одразу, якщо ви звернули увагу.
Ну, а так нормально, борщем нагодували. Можна пару ночей переспати і щось шукати далі.
У місцевій громаді розповідають, що більшість переселенців згодом шукають окреме житло,
влаштовуються на роботу - вчителями, лікарями, на місцеві ферми й господарства.
На Хмельниччині живуть уже близько 150 тисяч вимушених переселенців.
Загалом по Україні лише офіційно такий статус мають майже п'ять мільйонів людей.